[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be taking a look at some
unpublished content from Harry Potter
and the philosopher stone scribblings
and drafts taken straight from JK
rowlings notes that never saw the light
of day these drafts will include an
original synopsis for the book that kept
getting rejected by Publishers a very
early draft of a page from philosopher
stone where you'll notice that draco's
surname used to be sponge another very
early draft of one of the earliest pages
of philosopher stone a page one draft of
chapter 6 The Journey from Platform 9
and three quarters and a page two draft
of chapter 6 if you enjoy peeling back
the layers of the story and uncovering
secret unpublished tidbits then let's
not wait any further old synopsis the
original synopsis of philosopher stone
which I sent out to Publishers and which
kept winging its way back Harry Potter
lives with his aunt Uncle and Cousin
because his parents died in a car crash
or so he has always been told the DLI
don't like Harry asking questions in
fact they don't seem to like anything
about him especially the very odd things
that keep happening around him which
Harry himself can't explain the dy's
greatest fear is that Harry Will
discover the truth about himself so when
letters start arriving for him near his
11th birthday he isn't allowed to read
them however the do's aren't dealing
with an ordinary Postman and at midnight
on Harry's birthday the gigantic rubius
Hagrid breaks down the door to make sure
Harry gets to read his post at last
ignoring the horrified desley Hagrid
informs Harry that he is a wizard and
the letter he gives Harry explains that
he's expected at Hogwart School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry in a month time
to the desy's fury Hagrid also reveals
the truth about Harry's past Harry did
not receive the scar on his forehead in
a car crash it is really the mark of the
great dark sorcerer Voldemort who killed
Harry's mother and father but
mysteriously couldn't kill him even
though he was a baby at the time Harry
is famous among the witches and wizards
who live in secret all over the country
because Harry's miraculous survival
marked Voldemort's downfall so Harry who
has never had friends or family worth
the name sets off for a new life in the
Wizarding World he takes a trip to
London with Hagrid to buy his Hogwarts
equipment robes W cauldron beginner's
draft and potion kit and shortly
afterwards sets off for Hogwarts for
King's cross station Platform 9 and 3/4
to follow in his parents' footsteps
Harry makes friends with Ronald Weasley
Sixth and his family to go to Hogwarts
and tired of having to use secondhand
spell books and to miny Granger clest
girl in the year and the only person in
the class to know all the uses of
dragon's blood together they have their
first lessons in Magic astronomy up on
the tallest tower at 2: in the morning
hology out in the green houses where the
next up I've got a very early draft of
one of the first pages of philosopher
stone a fat kind of cactus in the corner
of the greenhouse which moaned in a
feeble sort of voice that its spines
were aching corel's classes were a bit
of a joke everyone was was hoping for
Gruesome spine chilling classes on dark
magic but with quirrel in charge they
couldn't somehow get him properly the
right mood his classroom smelled
strongly of garlic the story went that
ever since a narrow escape from a
vampire in Romania quel had lived in
fear that it would come and get him he
seemed almost as frightened of his
students as the trolls werewolves and
hags he was teaching them about jamus
finegan and Dean Thomas had a bet on to
see how long corl would stutter over a
single word in each less
Madame mcgonagal who taught
Transfiguration was as different from
quirrel as it was possible to be she was
very strict and Allowed no messing about
Transfiguration is one of the most
difficult and dangerous kinds of magic
she told them in their first lesson
anyone playing the fool will leave my
class and not come back then she
demonstrated how to turn a desk into a
pig and back again they were all very
very impressed as Percy Weasley had
predicted however she gave them a single
m and told them they would first be
learning how to turn them into needles
it really was horribly difficult after
two lessons only hermani Granger had
managed to make any difference to her
match Madame mcgonagal showed the class
how Hermione's match had gone pointed in
silvery and aione beamed at the praise
and then there was Snape who taught
potions in and here's the page that
follows but you'll notice that draco's
last name is spongin and not Malfoy
large and gloomy dungeon lined with
glass jars some held brilliant jewel
colored liquids others pickled roots and
various bits of creatures Harry tried to
change his mind about Snape at the start
of term banquet he' got the idea that
Snape didn't like him now after the very
first potions lesson he knew that he had
been wrong Snape didn't dislike Harry he
hated him as he called the register at
the start of their first lesson together
Snape glanced up to look at each student
as they answered yes sir when Harry
answered Snape's black eyes flashed as
he stared at him for a long while and a
twisted smile twisted his thin mouth ah
yes Potter he said a new celebrity Draco
spongin snorted loudly and Harry flushed
with anger the first year gryffindors
and Suites had potions together which
gave the gryffindors the chance to see
the truth of what everyone said about
Snape that he was vicious to everyone
except members of his house Snape
finished taking the register and cast a
long look around at the 20 students his
black eyes glittering addressed his new
students potions he said you are here to
learn the subtle science and exact
Artistry of potion making no foolish
wand waving in here many of you will
hardly believe this is Magic how very
few of you clothe headed young adults
will understand the beauty of the softly
simmering cold
and its shimmering fumes the delicate
power of liquids that steal through
human veins bewitching the body and in
snaring the mind I can teach you how to
bottle Fame and Glory decant power stoer
death but how few of you dunderheads
will be able to learn Snape paused and
his glittering black eyes rounded over
the class no one spoke or moved Snape
was one of those teachers whose
silencers you didn't break aione Granger
who and that's the end of that page I
particularly liked slyther writes unless
of course I was reading that wrong next
we're on to the page one draft of
chapter 6 The Journey from Platform 9
and 3/4s Harry's last month at the
dersley wasn't fun true Dudley really
was now so scared of Harry he wouldn't
stay in the same room and Aunt Petunia
and Uncle Vernon didn't shut Harry in
his cupboard or force him to do anything
or shout at him in fact they didn't
speak to him at all half terrified half
Furious
they acted as though any chair where
Harry was sitting was empty while an
improvement in many ways this did become
depressing after a while Harry spent
most of his time in his room with his
owl he pinned a piece of paper on the
wall with the days left before September
the 1st marked on it and he tick them
off every night on the 31st of August he
thought he'd better speak to his uncle
about getting to King's cross next day
so he went down to the living room where
the derley had a quiz show on television
Harry cleared his throat to tell them he
was there and Dudley squealed and ran
out of the room uh Uncle Vernon Uncle
Vernon grunted to show he was listening
um I need to be at King's cross tomorrow
to to go to Hogwarts Uncle Vernon
grunted again would it be all right if
you gave me a lift grunt Harry supposed
that was yes thank you he said and he
was about to leave the room when Uncle
Vernon actually spoke to him funny way
to get to a wizard school he said the
train magic carpets will got punctures
have they Harry didn't say anything
where is this school then I don't know
said Harry so how you going to get there
I just take the platform from 9 and 3/4
next up we've got another draft from the
same chapter Harry woke up at 5:00 the
next morning and was too excited and
nervous to get back to sleep he got up
and pulled on his jeans because he
didn't want to walk into something in
wh's robes in front of the kid on the
train he checked his Hogwarts list yet
again to make sure he had everything he
needed
made sure Hedwig was safely in her cage
and waited for the Desy to get up
Harry's huge heavy trunk had been loaded
into the desy's trunk Aunt Petunia had
talked Dudley into sitting next to Harry
and they set off he'd have to ask
someone he stopped a passing guard and
but didn't dare mention Platform 9 and
3/4 when the guard had never heard of
Hogwarts and when Harry couldn't tell
him the city or town it was near he
started to think Harry was just trying
to annoy him as if Harry was trying to
annoy him on purpose in desperation
Harry asked him for the train that left
at 11:00 but there wasn't one in the end
the guards strowed away muttering about
wasted people wasting his time Harry
tried not to panic as wishing the large
the large distant clock over the rivals
board in front of Harry he had 10
minutes left to get on the train and he
had no idea how to do it he was stranded
in the middle of the station with a
trunk he could hardly lift pocket and a
pocket full of Wizard's money and a
large owl what a what on Earth was he
going to do and that concludes the draft
readings for today apologies if at times
it sounded a bit confusing some of these
old drafts are exceedingly difficult to
read especially with all the words
crossed out and replaced if you want
more draft readings let me know down in
the comment section below until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to
live